okay so so what's data modeler it's you
know sort of depends on your point of
view you know the classic story of the
blind men and the and the elephant each
looking at at an elephant and I just
happen to have a rhino in my photo
collection so it was close enough I mean
the approximation is very important in
in data analysis so depending upon your
your need your you know is it the rapid
data analysis the ability to quickly
turn around things do you care about
generating human interpreta balada land
deriving the insight from those is
variable selection the factory I'm you
have in many multivariate systems who
get lots and lots of variables
correlated redundant how do we choose
from those what we what we need to do
there's also an aspect of if I'm going
to use a model for prediction and that's
really the the reason why you care about
models it's trust ability I mean your
conventional to sync model a single
model is big pile of trust me so you say
how do I I want to I want to trust my
prediction someone know it's good when
my winter my predictions suspect and
then the other aspect is once we get to
this trust will model then then we
actually have the foundation for what we
call active design of experiments in
other words to target my next collected
data point to be the one with the
maximum value and fidelity in terms of
revealing the underlying mechanisms the
technology we use is symbolic regression
basically this means throwing into a vat
your data the variables some operators
and constants and just letting it
percolate based on survival the fittest
to determine models that
capture the behavior of the data now
what we want to do in this process is
you know where we care about primitive
root models we wanted to be simple and
want to be accurate so those are the
sort of primary drivers in this
evolutionary process and as a result you
will be hypothesizing many disparate
models you come through and reject them
refine them and you know evolve simple
models if a variable is not important
that's going to be driven out we go back
here so this is just an illustration
this is the pareto front plot here
showing the trade-off of complexity
versus accuracy what we have typically
in a system is a is a sweet spot this
this knee of this knee of the curve
which is where there's the best
trade-off and as you see that mean this
little example human interpreta balada
land ensing down into that sort of a
space so the process is an option Iser
not an optimizer in the sense that we're
rather than being in the conventional
analysis mode of hypothesis test
hypothesis new hypothesis cycling
through where the human is providing all
of the sequence of hypotheses we provide
a framework we say which variables
should be included as a general rule
very loosely defined what date is
available and then let the evolutionary
process filter this down and isolate you
know build the models and and select the
variables and the model development is
is infinite because there are an
infinite number of models which will fit
a finite data set exactly right and so
if we want to loose approximation
there's an even more infinite number of
models that are appropriate but what we
want to do is come sweeping in at the
end
and extract the insight out of the
process the implications here is is the
transparency that we're looking at human
interpretable models so rather than a
black box or a neural net or something
like a random forests or support vector
machine we're getting something that we
could look at the equation or the
expression describing the response
behavior and and say well that's funny
or what does that mean we also have the
ability to look at the models and say
are there building blocks that are
successful in terms of good models like
and does that then derive in insight and
we were doing some consulting work for a
chemical company and you know the the
difference between these two
temperatures of distillation column was
you know very important for predicting
the quality of the stuff that they're
developing so that was something that
they were interested but in this
evolutionary process we're developing
you know thousands and tens of thousands
maybe hundreds of thousands of models
and when we're all said and done we're
going to have a bunch that are
approximately equivalent in terms of
simplicity and accuracy we can exploit
that to build trust of all models where
we've got this in these trustful models
are going to agree where there's
constrained by data otherwise they
wouldn't be good models and they will
disagree when either the underlying
system changes or we ask it to
extrapolate into a new region so then
when you have that ability for a
trustful model you can use it to target
your data collection so now if you
imagine I'm designing a new material I
want to sample this data space and then
my next data collection because if the
experiments are expensive is too
go where the the model is saying there's
maximum divergence between my in my
trustable models I'm gonna go lock that
that point down in and collect that
information okay so trust of all models
I mean this is the response plot
explorer but basically here you see the
illustration of this collection of
models and so you have a prediction but
then we also see disagreement as we move
away from from the truth point here
we've used an actual sample point is the
green dot as we move away from it into
unsampled space the the agreement
disappears okay so what over the last
decade we've developed as data modeler
which is an add-on package for
Mathematica 400 functions fully
documented you don't use all of them
during the course of a normal analysis
but but they're they're exposed using
the notebook interface for the
development of analyses and one hundred
percent Mathematica now and we've got
clients to me very happy with this that
we sell there is one problem with with
this notebook interface metaphor that we
have in Mathematica and that is shift
enter because it is amazing we have had
PhD electrical engineers that you know
shift debtor they moved the mouse over
to the cell bracket and click on it they
hold the shift key everything and then
they get the result and they do that
every time and it's just sort of this
touch typing free form control freak
thing that you have with a notebook
interface you know there's large chunk
of the world that doesn't respond to
that
so we need to figure out what you're
going to do to eliminate shift enter so
are our approach is I guess a little
less than a year ago we started working
on developing a GUI front end for the
thing and again no shift you know try to
minimize the shift dinners you've got
this problem if you've got a you know
very very powerful environment that's
you know used for automotive analysis
chemical process industries medical
predictions law I mean the end of course
you know hedge funds I mean there's
there's a wide variety of our user base
it's very powerful but how do you how do
you balance the power in the interface
so on that note let's go to so here's
the one shift enter that's still left in
the in the systems is to launch it there
so I open a project and this is when be
channeling my inner Steven here because
I got this particular build about an
hour ago so we're going to hopefully
everything all hangs together
sigh load of run this analysis of course
before and I'm going to select we're
going to model a female literacy
fraction just as a toy problem okay okay
so first thing you need to do so this is
we've been partnering should mention
Ariel sepulveda pronto analytics has
been developing the GUI with us but the
ability to just sort of explore the data
you see we have a lot of missing missing
records first thing you want to do of
course is to choose you know what's my
target variable and then is there a
column in the data set in this case the
the countries of the world of this this
thing is is a combination of country
data augmented with data of scraped for
you know gun usage alcoholism tobacco
use World Bank data that's all sort of
integrated together you know the raw
data is 240 countries of the world in
231 columns and then you can you know
then you find sub variable sets so let's
explore the data and here this first
view is the data summary table and it's
a quick overview of the data set so
we've categorized you know how
consistent is the data you know what's
its class is it a continuous variable
does it look like it's categorical
what's its you know zero-crossing
behavior because that affects if I want
to do I mean the not quite implemented
here but implemented
in the the pro version if you will a
data modeler analysis of you know how do
i wanted to rescale of variables but
what we see here is is this just this
view is if I'm analyzing literacy
fraction of God you know a lot of small
countries in the world so I may want to
be normalizing inputs by population or
some other factor and also see that I've
got six out of seven continents covered
now I can also come in here and of
course plot the data now it's a little
it's a little cluttered so I'm going to
I'm going to come in and I'm going to
turn off the tix and that gives me a
little bit of a cleaner view but I i
also say okay i'm looking more at the at
the behavior relative to the female
literacy let's let's sort it by that and
do it a plot that way now I've got this
graph I can also capture capture this
button here well will capture it to our
report notebook so here we see reports
that we can gather and I'll check the
box and I'll I'll move it to the report
and I'll come back to the data
exploration the data complete this map
you know for many industrial systems you
can sort of count on the the data being
truly numeric you do get some surprises
that get uncovered were you know
somebody substituted minus 9 99 in for
the for the missing data so this is the
sort of thing that the data summary
table will capture and flag for you
because you get this big big spike at
that one value but here we see that
we've got a lot of missing data Green is
numeric yellow is is non new red as
non-numeric we can look at the data
completeness plot
and see that South Sudan and pitcairn
islands aren't very well populated in
terms of their their data records and
then we can look at the the variables
that we have in our in our data set
bivariate plot doesn't doesn't make
sense it means you're looking at all
pairwise combinations I can go and I've
got some models that I variables that I
used and this is just a pairwise
scatterplot above the diagonal we do the
full range and below it's the zooming in
on the details with an automatic plot
range and of course data histograms on
the diagonal correlation chart the
correlations but the opening going who
we should look at all of them and what
we see here is we'll just put the bar
origin on the bottom and that will that
will kill our 230 labels 240 labels so
we're modeling literacy fraction we're
going to see that our female literacy
fraction literacy fraction and male
literacy fraction of course pretty
highly coupled as our other variables
okay and the correlation matrix plot is
similarly going to show takes a while to
a little bit couple 10 seconds so to
calculate but it's you know showing us
the that the all pairwise correlations
now the key here is we've gone through
and we've got a lot of correlated
variables to our targeted targeted input
and we've also violating you know many
of the assumptions so so blue is highly
correlated so we've got a lot of highly
correlated inputs okay so now let's go
look at generating bottles
and I have options here to control which
functions i'm going to use i can control
which of the how many variables i'm
going to allow in my models if there's a
limit on the power levels so and also i
can have here i have comments that can
attach to to my my each round of
modeling so in the interest of time
let's let's jump to the analysis phase
and let's retrieve interesting models
from round five okay
oh that's not quite what I want
oh oh cancel okay thank you because all
right so now I'm going to go back to my
user my my model set of round five
alright just let that alright so this is
this is all my models I've got three
thousand model or two thousand models
i've developed have done a bunch of 10
minute runs quad-core processor running
four of them at a time in parallel i'm
going to now go to my my interesting
round five models load them and show
some of the analysis tools so we've done
is we've got had all these models I can
sort the models i can say i want to take
the restrict the number of variables two
to three variables and say you know how
many have three variables do those sorts
of tests but if i look at a model
dimensionality table that's taking the
view of partitioning the data into its
into its number of variables as
containing and here we go so so what we
see is is that we have a lot of
different paths to success for our
models so we have four variable models I
can have you know country latitude total
which is alcohol consumption in country
various factors that are coming in I can
look at my variable presence chart and
this is what we can
down to is the the factors that have
been important that it emerged from the
evolutionary process as drivers I can
also break my my models up into their
individual evolutionary searches and
that is useful because it can highlight
mechanisms for variable variables that
maybe aren't useful in by themselves but
in conjunction with another variable in
some particular expression form they
will occasionally be discovered and at
that point they'll be exploited by the
evolutionary process and and be
highlighted so here we see for the most
part variables are heavily used but
cigarettes per capita is on average in
sixty percent of the models at this
stage of the the modeling sequence but
it's you know occasionally one run at
least it was up to a hundred percent and
occasionally down to only being in
twenty percent of the models so we can
also take that information and look at
the meta variable distributions now this
is this is very important because I can
see building blocks that I might want to
exploit subsequently so let's build cook
save I we're out of time and jump to our
ensemble and look at a ensemble
prediction plot and this is a plot of my
predictions of all these bottles and we
see is the scatter of the of the data so
of the individual model so we you know
as you know we had of you were paying
attention in there about a twenty eighty
percent r squared so it's not an
incredibly accurate model which you
shouldn't expect that from a social
science data set and then this would
this is supposed to be popping up the
country name that would be associated
with each of these outliers I think I've
run out of time so I'm going to close
out there and not show you some of the
other features but there's a struggle to
to have this much complexity be
accessible so questions ah it's under
the hood it's it's just mathematical
sets constraint I'm going to assume
that's the same as as data modeler
proper and we've got users that are
pushing two million records into it
we've done some stuff with 10,000
variables because you can handle this
wide array type situation so even though
you have more columns then you have data
records you can still pull out
information from that search process
because your your value of simplicity so
you have a constraint of you know I want
each model to be supported by four or
five data points if you will and and you
get this level of fidelity so you can
handle sort of the wide and you know
we've done it with some cancer
prognostics data were you know four
hundred samples one hundred or a hundred
samples hundred patients and 400
proteins that that have been involved
okay anything else